und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend des corona virus ist nicht gebannt
es ist wieder da und ziemlich massiv
dort wo es offenbar seinen ausgangspunkt
hatte in china diesmal aber nicht in der
provinz diesmal in peking
erste fälle nach zwei monaten natürlich
sind jetzt alle parolen vom sieg des
überlegenen systems über die pandemie
noch zweifelhafter als sie ohnehin schon
waren aber das ist jetzt nicht so
wichtig wichtig ist die frage was dort
wirklich geschehen ist jetzt geschieht
und weiter passieren kann stephanie
schöne bauen ist für uns in peking das
corona virus ist zurück in peking und
die menschen reagieren mit panikkäufen
dieser lieferservice für frische waren
online zu bestellen macht heute in
peking einen erschreckend guten umsatz
heute das doppelte also mindestens 30
prozent mehr bestellungen bekommen die
leute haben wieder angst raus zu gehen
dass es nicht sicher ist heute morgen
werden die menschen in peking und im
ganzen land von diesen bildern
aufgeschreckt hundertschaften der
militärpolizei regeln einen der größten
märkte pekings auf dem großmarkt im
südwesten der stadt waren sechs
mitarbeiter am corona virus erkrankt
massentests werden durchgeführt
wir haben bei 1.940 personen die auf dem
großmarkt arbeiten einen corona test
durchgeführt von 517 ausgewerteten
speichelproben wurden 45 positiv auf
kipp 19 getestet auf dem markt werden
neben gemüse vor allem fleisch und fisch
verkauft die meisten restaurants
kantinen und supermärkte in peking
beziehen ihre ware von diesem großmarkt
das virus auch auf einem schneidebrett
für importierten lachs gefunden worden
die stadtregierung hat strikt reagiert
in elf viertel rund um den markt dürfen
die bewohner ihre wohnungen vorerst
nicht verlassen
einige provinzen warnen davor nach
peking zu reisen und viele bereiten sich
auf einen erneuten lockdown vor ich habe
angst dass ich mich infizieren könnte
und mein kind auch wir werden versuchen
nicht auszugeben
es ist unmöglich in so kurzer zeit
dieses virus vollständig einzudämmen
die waren des großmarktes werden nun
entsorgt die menschen haben angst vor
der zweiten corona bälle angst vor all
den entbehrungen und wirtschaftlichen
folgen die das virus mit sich bringt in
china hat die regierung das system wenn
man will
schlimme fehler gemacht das land war am
anfang auch in der schlimmsten lage
nämlich auf pole position als saas co2
dort auftauchte wusste man zum
verzweifeln wenig darüber
man musste aber reagieren als noch wenig
klar war
im akuten hotspot brasilien war das
völlig anders als dort die ersten fälle
kamen wusste die ganze welt was zu tun
war aber brasilien hat einen präsidenten
der über corona lachte mehr als 40.000
brasilianer sind nun tot viele mehr
haben angst zu recht christoph referat
berichtet es sollte ein moment der ruhe
und würde sein kreuz an der copacabana
im gedenken an die krone opfer
brasiliens doch die ruhe währt nicht
lange ein mann greift das mahnmal an
es sei alles lüge der linken panikmache
die toten gebe es nicht mein vater wird
sich mein sohn ist an diesem scheiß
gestochen er war 25 jahre alt und der
hier führt sich auf wie ein clown
es sind anhänger von präsident ball zu
nahrung die immer wieder stören
die organisatoren des mahnmals sind
entsetzt das ist eine polarisierung die
wir noch nie erlebt haben in der
geschichte unserer demokratie es ist
viel wut raserei viel leidenschaft für
politische parteien und ideologien
sie macht die menschen blind für die
fakten fakt ist dass hier was wie
wahnsinn wirkt hat methode und ein
anführer es ist der präsident selbst der
die realität der pandemie leugnet auf
facebook wendet er sich direkt an seine
anhänger
niemand hat sein leben verloren weil es
kein beatmungsgerät oder intensiv bett
gab es kann sein dass das ein oder
zweimal passiert ist es wäre gut wenn du
der vor ort ist versuchst wenn es bei
dir in der nähe ein krankenhaus gibt
irgendwie rein zu kommen und zu filmen
nicht nur dass eindringenden
krankenhäuser illegal und gefährlich es
ist doch eine verhöhnung der opfer
gerade in den armen vierteln sterben
viele zu hause ohne arzt ohne test ohne
in der korona statistik aufzutauchen
brasilien testet zu wenig wir können nur
die fälle testen die ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert werden
wir rechnen also dass renault circa zehn
bis 15 prozent der fälle wirklich
erkennen
doch schon die offiziellen zahlen werden
zum politischen problem für einen
präsidenten der korona als kleine grippe
abgetan hat und auf einmal meldet die
regierung letzte woche die zahlen erst
verzögert dann gar nicht und dann nur
noch für die letzten 24 stunden
wenn sie die gesamtsumme wollen addieren
sie einfach selbst sagt bolzenius vize
general worauf er ist der oberste
gerichtshof beendet die trickserei für
kritiker steckt hinter dem manipulations
versucht die anhaltende strategie
goldzone aros grenzen auszutesten und
damit die demokratie zu schwächen
während man die traditionellen medien
und journalisten angreift und versucht
sie einzuschüchtern beginnt man auch
daten und statistiken zu verschleiern
dazu kommt noch die strategie die
sozialen medien zu nutzen um diese
informationen zu verbreiten und die
öffentliche meinung zu beeinflussen
doch es regt sich widerstand immer mehr
menschen gehen gegen die regierung auf
die straße es rumort in brasilien wie
seit jahren nicht mehr zurück nach
europa da gab es um mitternacht
wunderbar emotionale augenblicke an der
deutsch polnischen grenze momente von
denen man geglaubt hatte dass man sie
nie wieder erleben würde
leider musste dafür vor drei monaten ein
ganz anderer
ertragen werden von dem man hoffen
durfte dass er nie wieder kommen würde
dagegen wegen corona die deutsch
polnische grenze erst mal wieder zu nun
also wieder auf natalie steger berichtet
agatha ist einigermaßen geschafft es
brummt im laden und genau deshalb sind
sie im friseursalon zufrieden
seit dem morgen sind die deutschen
kunden zurück wir haben auf den heutigen
tag sehr lange gewartet seit drei
monaten
es hat sehr gut angefangen mit vielen
kunden jetzt warten wir noch auf weitere
der grenzorte schien oft nur 230
einwohner aber beachtliche 36
friseursalons es geht ums geschäft im
grenzgebiet aber auch um treffen unter
freunden viele emotionale momente um
mitternacht deutsche können wieder nach
polen einreisen
das tut auch der oberbürgermeister von
frankfurt er trifft seinen kollegen in
der nachbarstadt slubice abstandsregeln
kurz vergessen
ein wunderschöner tag für uns heute hier
um hat es glaub ich auch gemerkt haben
eigentlich uns vorgenommen nur mit den
ellenbogen aber es ging nicht anders
es wird gefeiert auch in görlitz und der
polnischen nachbarstadt zgorzelec nutzen
die bürgermeister die erste gelegenheit
und schaffen die barrieren weg endlich
kehrt der alltag zurück im polnischen
grenzgebiet haben die polnischen
kleinunternehmer gelitten
eugene auf dollar lebt man fast
ausschließlich von den deutschen kunden
günstiges essen günstigerer tabak schon
am vormittag kommt ein bus aus berlin
jeden tag drauf gewartet hier kann man
so schön einkaufen
restaurantbesitzer angie musste vier
angestellte entlassen
er hat wie viele hier nicht verstanden
dass die regierung im fernen warschau
die grenzen so lange geschlossen hielt
dieses virus hat doch keine nationalität
falls das virus in deutschland wäre
nicht aber in polen wäre eine
grenzschließung okay aber das virus hat
keine nationalität im polnischen
grenzgebiet hoffen sie nun dass die
pandemie nicht noch einmal zuschlägt
denn eine zweite grenzschließung würden
viele hier wirtschaftlich nicht
verkraften nachricht nun von gundula
gause
zusätzlich zur impfstrategie der eu
haben sich deutschland frankreich
italien und die niederlande zu einer im
fall jan zusammengeschlossen
gesundheitsminister sparen erklärte
gemeinsam mit der kommission wolle man
schneller und verhandlungs stärker
werden
es gehe darum millionen impfstoff dosen
für alle 27 eu staaten zu sichern
dazu wurde ein erster vertrag mit dem
britisch schwedischen pharmaunternehmen
astrazeneca geschlossen dass bis
jahresende einen impfstoff entwickelt
haben will
in london ebenso wie in paris haben
tausende gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt demonstriert in beiden
hauptstädten kam es zu ausschreitungen
in paris wurde eines mannes gedacht der
2016 nach 1
festnahme gestorben war ähnlich wie
george freud in den usa
die proteste wurden von rechtsextremen
gegen demonstranten gestört die polizei
griff ein auch um die menschen wegen
krone auseinanderzutreiben
anlässlich neuer vorwürfe über
rechtsextreme tendenzen bei der
bundeswehr eliteeinheit ksk hat
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer erneut betont extremismus
und rechtsextremismus hätten in der
bundeswehr keinen platz
der spiegel berichtet über rechtsextreme
umtriebe in der ksk auch die neue
wehrbeauftragte des bundestages hügel
spd fordert schnelle aufklärung
im bistum limburg haben 70 experten
dutzende aktenkundige fälle von
sexuellem missbrauch im
verantwortungsbereich der katholischen
kirche dort seit 1946 untersucht heute
wurde der projektbericht in der
frankfurter paulskirche an einen
vertreter der betroffenen übergeben
darin enthalten 61 konkrete maßnahmen um
sexualisierte gewalt und machtmissbrauch
künftig zu verhindern
eine unabhängige kommission soll die
umsetzung begleiten die brutale sperre
anlage um west-berlin die viel mehr war
als bloß eine mauer wirkte wie für die
ewigkeit gebaut es gab kaum jemanden
damals der wirklich glaubte dass dieses
monstrum zu seiner lebzeit verschwinden
würde
und dann geschah es doch die ganze welt
schaute nach dem 9 november 89 auf die
löcher in dieser mauer da standen aber
immer noch 155 kilometer davon bis heute
vor 30 jahren der große abriss begann
vielleicht ein bisschen zu komplett
meinen manche heute wo man los berichtet
die euphorie auch im sommer 90 noch groß
obwohl sieben monate seit mauerfall
vergangen strömen die berliner weiter zu
neuen übergängen
doch dieser tag ist anders am 13 juni
beginnt der totalabriss des betonkoloss
symbolträchtig an der bernauer straße
west berlins bürgermeister zur wendezeit
erinnert sich bis heute gut an die
stimmung damals an erhalt und
fortbestand größerer mauerabschnitte
dachte kaum jemand ganz überwiegende
meinung der menschen war das muss weg
besonders der berlinerinnen und der
berliner die wollten das ding einfach
nicht mehr sehen die hatten sagt und
deshalb gab es auch eigentlich keine
ernsthafte diskussionen darüber
so zieht es die touristen dieser tage an
das was von der mauer übrig blieb nur
durch corona fällt der ansturm auf east
side gallery und gedenkstätte spärlich
aus 30 jahre nach der wende hat sich die
stimmung offenbar gedreht statt freude
über abriss hört man zunehmend den
wunsch nach mehr mauer als zeugnis
deutscher geschichte die junge
generation die kennt die diese ganze
thematik ja gar nicht in der schule wird
das sehr sehr spät geleert sind schon
man hätte damals vielmehr stehen lassen
sollen ja weil natürlich sind jetzt
viele künstler dann irgendwie noch im
denkmal mit eingebracht und es ist
verändert natürlich dass das bild wie es
eigentlich wirklich war
dabei landeten viele mauerteile nicht im
schredder anfang der 90er herstellbaren
auf souvenirs von kleinen brocken bis
ganze bauteile kurz nach der wende
werden besonders attraktive stücke in
new york auf einem flugzeugträger
versteigert ronny heidenreich sucht
weltweit wo sich noch mauerteile
befinden heute stünden mehr attraktive
elemente in den usa als in deutschland
hatten wir schon die wir gestellt haben
gibt es ungefähr gegenwärtig 400
mauerteile denkt man inszenierte mauer
elemente in nahezu allen auf allen
kontinenten in über 40 ländern und die
zahl hat in den letzten jahren
exponentiell zugenommen
so lässt sich der anhaltende boom auch
preislich ablesen im internet muss für
komplette teile teils tief in die tasche
gegriffen werden
der vormals antifaschistische schutzwall
lässt sich also auch heute noch
kapitalistisch aus
die britische königin elizabeth die
zweite hat wie üblich ihren geburtstag
nachgefeiert wegen corona aber ohne das
offizielle militärparaden spektakel
sondern kleiner schlichte und mit
abstand auf schloss windsor
es war ein mini trooping dass die welsh
guards der queen präsentierten und die
wirkte auch ohne jubelnde massen am
jüngst im april war sie 94 geworden die
gewinnzahlen vom lotto lauten ohne
gewähr 14 20 36 38 41 43 superzahl 5
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text die angekündigten
heftigen sommergewitter und regenschauer
haben heute vor allem im nordosten
deutschlands schäden angerichtet
kristina k jetzt beginnt ihren unwetter
bericht im nördlichen niedersachsen
es war ein spektakuläres schauspiel
heute am himmel über deutschland das
nichts gutes verhieß nach wochenlanger
dürre haben die menschen im norden und
osten mit den folgen des unwetters zu
kämpfen so wie hier auf der a39 wo
schwerem regen hagelschauer folgen und
eine gefährliche eisbahnen entsteht die
autos nehmen langsam antworten bekommt
es maximal mit 30 40 stundenkilometer
fahren und dann hat der hg eingesetzt
und da war es natürlich ist er
allerersten runter von der autobahn
schutz suchen schutz suchen nicht so
einfach wenn das unwetter schon über
einem tobt mancher unternimmt
lebensgefährliche rettungsmanöver und
vermeintlich sichere orte können zur
falle werden diese holzhütte in lübeck
wird vom blitz getroffen
zwei männer werden hier schwer verletzt
brütende hitze und land unter auch
weiter östlich in brandenburg am abend
zieht das unwetter weiter nach süden und
meteorologen warnen es ist noch nicht
vorbei
zur stunde gelten noch unwetterwarnungen
für den süden hessens und den norden
bayerns morgen ist mit heftigen
gewittern und starkregen vor allem in
der mitte deutschlands zu rechnen
in dem streifen vom emsland bis franken
besteht wieder unwettergefahr trocken
und sonnig ist es nur im nordosten dort
bei bis zu 26 grad sonst wird es
frischer in den nächsten tagen kann es
im westen und süden schauer und gewitter
geben aber nicht mehr so heftig im
norden und osten wird es sonnig im süden
wieder wärmer hier nimmt die freundinnen
und kolleginnen dunja hayali den ball
auf mit aktuellem aus dem sport im dazu
passenden studio bleiben sie bei uns bis
[Musik]